[Music]
all righty streeters let's do this thing
[Music]
we're uh sitting at thrill hill
recording in the wilds of new jersey
having reconvened the e street band when
you get back together it's just a power
it's like a family reuniting
real friends for 40 years all
contributing something artistically
that's something special the greatest
thrill
in my life is standing behind that
microphone with you guys behind me
let's do it there's a
terrific unspoken kind of affinity
for what we're about to do faded
pictures
we showed up with no demos sent no
chance to write out charts and get to
know the songs
the way we do things capturing the
excitement while it's happening
the only other time we worked this way
would be born in the usa
when we play together it's 1977
all over again it's all about the songs
and
the inspiration with those songs comes
from what i know you guys are going to
be playing i hear the sound of your
guitar
you're not exactly sure where you're
going but you know if you jump on to
his energy and his direction you'll get
there together
you're holding on to just learn the
basic song
and then even bruce is kind of changing
his mind about things
don't play it up higher just don't play
so low
but invariably just get the claps and
get the lotta
it'll trigger an idea
[Music]
it's just gotten better blows my mind
bruce is one of the great songwriters in
history
it's a journey not so much the
destination and him
recognizing that is why he's a great
artist all my
happiness and all my faith
there's a moment where it all comes
together and it's fleeting
i've heard it described as catching
lightning in a bottle and that's
catching the magic
[Music]
perfect perfect
you